i'm a little worried about a plague tale
requiem stealth but its narrative and
characterization still have lots of
potential
they're coming
i can't you have to handle it yourself
are you sure
i love the plaguetail innocence despite
its straightforward moment-to-moment
gameplay it ended up being one of my
favorite games of 2019 thanks to the
fantastic art direction wonderful
performances and gripping story while
i'm very curious to see where the story
goes in requiem the gameplay faults and
all feel a little too familiar most of
these issues were easy to overlook back
in 2019 when it seemed like a sobo
studio was punching well above its
weight now however these same issues are
a bit harder to forgive requiem takes
place shortly after the first game and
is set in 14th century france during the
bubonic plague at the outset of the
hundred years war although both games
are set in a realistic depiction of
france the story often flirts with
gothic supernatural elements this is
easily one of the coolest things about
innocence and requiem and what sets it
apart from most third-person adventure
games the world is so wonderfully
detailed and everything has a macabre
sheen to it like in the original you
play as amesia a young girl tasked with
escorting her younger brother hugo
through a plague-stricken world infested
with rats and occupied by hostile
soldiers along with emesia's trusty
sling requiem introduces a crossbow as
you'd expect the crossbow is much
deadlier than emesia's sling however
bolts for it are harder to come by this
means that like innocence most
encounters demand a stealthier approach
you can throw objects to attract enemy
attention squeeze under tight spaces to
hide from view and track an enemy's
movements with a vision mode called rat
sense yes it's called rat sense the
first few enemy encounters in the
preview i played were not great after
emisia gets chased out of a lovely
little pilgrim encampment she stumbles
into some ruins and soldiers quickly
close in on her these first few areas
are cramped and filled with dead ends
making it far too easy for amecia to get
trapped if emisia gets caught by a
soldier he knocks her on the ground hugo
helps her back up and the soldier
conveniently waits for a second to give
you a chance to react from there amesia
can stun the soldier with a counter kill
the soldier with a single use knife or
run if emisia fails to react the guard
will kill her it's nice having more
options in combat than in the previous
game but the first few areas don't
really support them there weren't many
avenues of approach and when i did get
spotted and tried to run i'd get
cornered by guards even if i did counter
or kill a guard there usually wasn't
enough room to get past the rest of the
soldiers this meant that pure stealth
was really my only option i quickly
realized that if i got caught it was
best to just restart the encounter now i
don't mind stealth games in fact i love
metal gear solid and i'm a die hard
splinter cell fan but being sneaky isn't
what makes those games fun it's how you
can poke and prod at the simulation
allowing you to get past enemies in
creative ways in these early encounters
i felt like my best bet was to throw
pots into conveniently placed armor bins
to draw an enemy's attention this
distraction-based approach to stealth
wasn't great in the first game and it
doesn't seem to have evolved all that
much here thankfully options did open up
a bit more as i progressed once emesian
hugo made it through the caverns they
ended up in an open canyon there was
grass to hide in and cliffs to clamber
up creating more room to maneuver using
hugo's rat sense and careful timing i
managed to slip past most enemies i say
most because i found my way onto a ridge
and hid behind a bush to wait for a
guard to pass however the guard spotted
me right through the bush and rushed me
i tried to hop down from the ridge but
an invisible wall stopped me in my
tracks the guard cornered emesia and
killed her that inconsistency with the
ai combined with the arbitrary
restriction of the invisible wall robbed
the conflict of any tension and
concluded with a cheap death
new to a plague tale requiem is the
ability to control a mischief of rats
and turn any enemy who dares to venture
away from an open flame into a tasty
snack it adds a nice wrinkle to combat
and lets you quickly dispatch enemies if
there's a rat horde nearby apart from a
few tutorialized encounters hugo can
only control the rats for a limited
amount of time so you'll need to plan
your route carefully these segments felt
a lot more dynamic one in particular
took place in an open-air bathhouse that
spilled out into a field there was
plenty of room to maneuver and
systematically picking off enemies with
the rats to clear a path for omesi and
hugo added a much needed layer of
strategy to the combat the second half
of the preview followed amesia hugo and
a gruff soldier named arno as they
searched for a boat the first part of
this chapter mainly consisted of puzzles
as the trio navigated through a rat
infested cave system these puzzles
weren't complicated but they did offer a
welcome change of pace from the combat
using emesia's sling and specialized
ammo you needed to carefully light a
path through the cave so the party could
safely pass through i'm curious to see
how these puzzles evolve as emesia's
arsenal expands combat issues aside what
i'm really looking forward to in requiem
is the narrative this preview consisted
of two chapters that roughly took place
in the middle of the game so it was
tough to follow along with the plot that
said the acting seemed just as strong as
it was in the first game hugo's voice
actor in particular stood out despite
all the horrific stuff he's seen there
was still an innocent charm to him that
offers a reprieve from the harsh world
we're looking for an island it has two
teeth and there's a bird and a small
lake and flowers it's probably an island
with two large mountains
we were told you could help us find it
now i did run into a few bugs during my
preview but bugs are to be expected when
it comes to pre-release builds the game
is incomplete and typically developers
use that final stretch of development to
squash remaining glitches however a
plaguetail requiem is out in just over a
month and i had numerous progress
halting bugs that forced me to reload
encounters and restart entire sections i
wish i had footage of this but
unfortunately we weren't allowed to
capture our gameplay in one instance
arno asked me to light his shield on
fire in order to get through an area
overrun with rats arno refused to
brandish his shield so i couldn't light
it in another situation i simply
couldn't crouch i checked the key
bindings and swapped from mouse and
keyboard to a controller to no avail
reloading the save didn't fix the issue
so i ultimately restarted the section
while isobo does have some time to iron
out these issues it's worth keeping an
eye on the bug situation as we approach
the game's release date i hope these
issues are exclusive to me and my setup
but in my experience that's usually not
the case overall i am cautiously
optimistic for requiem i'm excited to
see where asobo takes the story and its
memorable cast of characters even if the
combat does end up falling flat for me a
plaguetail requiem comes to pc
playstation 5 and xbox series snx on
october 13th be sure to keep an eye out
for our review in the coming weeks
don't be ashamed sweetheart it suits you
what do you want
your boat we need to go to lacuna no
questions asked
you